so I'm out in my Grandma's place
and I forgot to bring a mouse pad but my
grandma has this uh this puppy mouse pad
so it's working well I'm away from my
natural habitat
for a few days
tis the season of Thanksgiving and
turkeys and and Black Friday deals yeah
we have the merch command
I decided to have a coupon code for
Black Friday
starting on Tuesday because why not
okay playing Bishops 83
alerts are muted
upon giving me some small time odds
we have a queen's Pawn opening
opening okay
try and keep some Pace here
uh Bishop B5 tricky move
Rook C8
every time I encounter this line I
forget the theory
E6 is also playable but sometimes can
run into issues
I think Rook seed and queen B6
and then there's some crazy lines like
C4
I mean that seems like white is more for
getting the theory
I'm taking a lot of time here
I've had so many games as white where
I'll play Knight E5 take take and then
trap the rook and win the exchange and
the first 10 moves
um like even a lot of like strong title
players will fall for that trap
that's usually in the E6 lines
25 yeah Queen B6
white was threatening to take tapeish
Basics so
this is one way to resolve matters
at a similar position once against
komsky
where he tried to cement a knight on C5
oh am I in trouble here
H4 is coming if I play Bishop E4 F3
Bishop g6h4
it's not the end of the world but uh
it's maybe not so pleasant
I should have played um maybe H6 instead
of E6
there there
I have a funny idea
I don't think it works though
wait
so I'm calculating each four here
H5 take
Bishop takes F6
tick tick tick that's no good I think I
have to play H5
not super Pleasant
I lost my opening time Advantage too
Knight E4
[Music]
oh
I'm in trouble here
I walked into this G4 H4 thing and now I
have sad Pawn structure Rook G1 I don't
think hurts me too much
I'm actually I'm remembering a game I
played against Levon aronian where he
absolutely crushed me in a very similar
line
it may have been the exact same position
we film contents several months ago
on the chess up board
I wonder if I can find the the file
going for C5
I think what I'll do if I find that file
I will
make a YouTube video out of this game
and then that game
still not sure what's going to happen in
this game I could take with Knight
although probably take with Bishop
rookie eight
now if my king gets H7 it's actually
really really safe the problem is the
king is tied down into the pawn so I
think I start with this
um even though it looks kind of passive
I'm also remembering a video a niche
giri did
it was on kasparovchess.com
and he was talking about the structure
how it looks ugly
but when the King goes to H7 it's
actually really safe
okay Rook F3 I think rookie seven
Queen side down to C2
Rook C3 might be coming
that's annoying
Queen B8
I want to play this
I was turning into a bullet game
I hung upon
it takes maybe like E5
I gotta Focus here
A4 may be coming
yeah I don't want to trade Queens but I
don't want to get mated
Queen
D7
I might have to
okay and kick the queen out
my king is still really safe
passive move again but
making some progress
okay the knight's gonna reach the
Promised Land
or will it
don't hurt me
okay Promised Land achieved
hey I want on time okay
oh wow what a game
that was a close game
um
I was probably a much worse out of the
opening
it was a line that I thought I knew
better than my opponent
I just
I forgot about this trap
I guess I should play H6 here
and Knight C5 then E6
wait where'd the Turning go
I don't know if I can even
oh that's Donya
wait what
wait is Daniel
wait where's my game
what is this
oh I'm playing Darrow
that's so weird why didn't the game like
pop up
okay I'm playing Darrow
I played daro recently
I played them from the airport in
Toronto
he played Knight C6
and then I looked at the game afterwards
should I conclude I concluded castling
trying to remember is a D5
no D5 E5
push rate six
maybe just F3
man I already started the game giving
timeouts
yeah there's all these like Center Fork
tricks but they don't quite work because
I have Bishop E5 and there's a queen
Rook battery in the end yeah I played
daro I think it was two weeks ago when I
flew back from Toronto I was like going
through the airport security while
trying to play
from my phone
and then he just crushed me but this is
a very similar line
okay now E5 looks attractive
but E5 take take we trade Queens
from
Bishop B5
so I'm basically using the bishop to
fight for the E5 Square
discouraging Pawn E5
now Bishop H6 looks interesting
there's also D5
there's still E5 too actually
tick tick yeah because after I take take
I win the bishop
this bishop is maybe a bit misplaced on
D7 and it takes away a square from the
Knight and a knight H4 Bishop h69
threatening G4 trapping the knights
and G4 is not so easy to stop I mean we
might see take take Knight G7 but that
could allow the eventual Knight G5 and
Queen H7
and G4 will also
block the Bishops on H3 can safely be
played
um can I just take take take
Bishop C4 also looks attractive
you should see four
I think I'll start with this
because I'm going to have like D5 in the
end
and it doesn't look good for black but I
just have to stay focused
in H3
there's at six
but F6 I have um this and this
is almost getting trapped there
I guess there's Bishop C8
Bishop b5a4 Bishop V4 B3
there's also
I think I'll start with A4
so Bishop here here here 94 they're in
Knight G5
it's really close to winning
um E6 first
I mean I just don't see the how black
stops 94.9 G5 Queen H7
so Bishop D5 I take with Rook Knight G5
I think it's Force mate
at least in that line
uh Queen E3 is idea
like this
nice game okay
that was a nice game
I I learned from my previous game
against him
because like the previous game I played
against in my plane Knight F3
which somehow allowed the ventral E5
but
yeah that was actually a really nice
position to like these pawns are so
strong Knight on G7 is um
it looks like a Defender but it doesn't
help defend H7
okay
playing another Grandmaster who is this
oh this is Anthony werig
I thought maybe like they're using a
pseudonym I played this person before
though okay
uh
we have D4
oh another London
okay I learned my lesson from that
previous game
oh C3 I meant to check this line
I'll just play um E6
nice thing about playing London is white
is I have options as black
oh do I want to go into this
I think I'll play the Queen C7 line
casting first and then Queen z7
there is a Gambit a really like cool
Gambit that Magnus played against ding
it featured uh
takes takes here Bishop A3 eventually
I forgot how it went though
some crazy line
so Knight F3 we transpose into what I
usually play
as white
and now I'm trying to remember like
Knight C6 and CD4 and then some Knight
E7 maneuver
it's so weird having this position is
black
okay he wants to play F4
hmm
I think I after F4 I go for this bishop
b796 Maybe
although that seems kind of slow and my
queen is vulnerable
I mean 97 still looks
like some idea
hmm
take
I remember watching some random video
I think it was a video by Katy satsias
really
who was like giving her recommendation
against London and she recommended
exactly this maneuver
in Knight D6 and she was saying like
that's all you need to know
uh
following her recommendation
B6
so this bishop actually can play a role
in supporting E4
as one of the plans for back in this
position is to
oh wait G4 is coming really quickly
I think I just sack upon
so G4 Knight T6 g594 takes takes takes
takes takes Bishop B7 I'll be down the
pond but I have the bishop here
oh Bishop B7 skewers forgot the g-pawns
missing at the end of that line
so it's not even a pawn sack
yeah I was gonna say the vision B7 plays
a nice role in controlling E4 Square
um
I think I played 94 anyway
E4
I mean we do trade Bishops
but 94 is useful and um eventually
getting an F6
I guess white can take twice and not
okay never mind
it should be seven now
six
F6 is double edge take take Rook G1 King
h8
and this move
dna5
E3 could be a bit vulnerable
I played similar positions as light
before like things can backfire very
quickly with the white pieces
but white still has some like dangerous
attacking ideas
like Knight G4 and Knight H6
can I take Rook C1 for Rook C8
I mean my G4 I'll play can you cheat
oh it's King could wind up stuck in the
center
and take sticks there's already Queen B4
takes Queen before I mean if takes I
have E3 ideas already
it's also beef okay so Queen B4
foreign
ER
I forgot about that move
the first step is not to get mated
there is my H6
it's not pleasant
foreign
foreign
foreign
oh what's my heart rate
heart rate had to pass 150 there
oh man
oh it's so close
like we were both on the verge of
getting needed
I was so fortunate that my queen is uh
controlling f8 here
so so fortunate
let's go okay
I was so close to flagging like I'm my
mouse and hand were shaking
I guess those two kind of correlate
I feel like the games have been really
nice too
like I really haven't played this line
against the London I mean I just didn't
want to get tricked because against the
C3 move oh I'm playing Fabiano oh dear
do I play a Stafford
uh
oh he knows everything
he's gonna play E4
he's gonna play a London
he's thinking okay
maybe he doesn't realize the game
started
oh he has two and a half points oh
that's funny
ah okay
um
I don't know what to play
I can't play a Stafford because he knows
what to do against it
I think I'll play a dragon dwarf
Dragon dwarf yeah let's play Dragon
dwarf
uh
not prepared to go into this
A4
yeah it's so important that I don't like
overthink things just have to move
quickly
A4 is a kind of Obby line
so there's ideas of sacking eventually
if I can win E4
foreign
there's 95
it takes a knight C6 maybe that's just
solid
and Bishop C6 Queen A5
yeah these are all like very typical
Dragon ideas
okay so I survived the opening kind of
um
that's maybe a little bit unpleasant
though
Knight c5b4
I don't think B4 is too harmful
and there is like E6 eventually Queen E7
Rook d8 but E6 could weaken D6
Queen C7
yeah I was thinking about this it's
really not bad
or he ate
because I want to reposition the Knight
now
and upon in D5 is doesn't combine great
with the light sword Bishop
C4 is coming
uh maybe F4 as well
C5
okay
it's still alive probably a little bit
worse
Queen D7 at some point
walks into Bishop G4
yeah pawns on light squares uh play a
role in restricting the bishop
and C6
to do
I mean Rook d8 is it really that bad
trying to win D5 so C6 takes takes I
have C5
so I was just trying to make sense of
ah but he takes a rook
[Music]
um
take C5
oh this doesn't look good
what about Queen C7
that just looks terrible
so take
wait take take no
I feel like 95.
I like E5 now
yeah it's not a good position
[Music]
I'm taking time but like I'm just in
trouble
okay I'll suck though oh no I can't even
my night's pinned what is this
I'm just getting smashed
foreign
passers
it's kind of rough
stop hurting me
oh no
why does he have so many queens
foreign
to make a third Queen
oh GG
that went downhill really quickly like I
thought it was slightly worse
and then he just played C5 C6
and
like my whole position just fell apart
I think maybe my knight should have
stayed on D7
or maybe I should just
have played something different I don't
know
he played well
he's kind of good at chess
okay new game
I'll address questions later
okay time for D4
yeah this is a line
I've gone into a decent amount
idea of 92 is F3 and
yeah
um
my knowledge pretty much ends here
so I gave away the bishop pair but okay
there's some awkward structure
I take on G5
and queen B6 queenside castling
it looks a little bit shaky
but it's my attempt to
call blocks Bluff
this isn't good some lag
yeah sorry if I'm driving frames
I might like reboot the stream
um after this game
and castle queenside
also another five no that doesn't work
take
it looks really risky but
I'm losing E5
but okay I'm up a pawn so
it might just be equal material
Bishop can't take as I take and then
take
Knight can take but then Bishop B5 some
funny lines
I always have to be
alert about the king and queen
don't want to get skewered
yeah Bishop d796
hey Queen F4
F4 might help black king G7
maybe just an 82.
hmm
Queen H4
there's Queen E3
foreign
six okay so E5 take take is not
happening
King B1
moving too slowly
rookie one huh
foreign
rookie one
does really work
those might just be losing
Knight's such a good Defender
ah so ticks takes Bishop takes I have
rookie King G7 Queen D4
and that's kind of tricky
a very weird position A6 might be played
86 I wonder if I can play Bishop E8
Savage move
I'm not sure how much that does though
wow
we're both getting very low on time
foreign
foreign
foreign
yeah I mean black was surviving to
93 was a good move
for a very Split Second I was thinking
work out for one but Yeah final position
is losing
good game I've felt so close
even like after losing the piece
um although maybe there's nothing like
it's hard to
create threats yeah normally title
choose as I stick with my main
repertoire sometimes I'll mix it up
if I know my opponent well
um
I actually studied this for Canty
it's a knight A3 move
I don't like I ever like ended up
playing the sign against canteen in our
match
ah what's the line though the problem
with looking at this a while ago
five
E5 looks interesting
I hope I'm not locking into some oh no
why did I think I had Bishop E3
oh E5 is just was just really bad
uh there's Queen E2
I guess
okay I've really botched this opening
but maybe there's some commentation
the Queen's being attacked
maybe five at some point
I did lose upon
yeah I thought I was being sneaky too
I have to check my files
so Bishop C3 is actually
maybe a threat although
I don't think it works
or does it
I'm trying it
okay
we've got to do something here
lh5
wow
take
there's F ticks
really
I think I was just winning now I mean
there's rookie Queen you sudden King I
fade but then Bishop H6
and there's not even Queen E5
Bishop takes his mate I
okay it's not so simple
it looks really close to good though
Bishop Basics first
I don't have much time
it was funny line um Rook H6
because I don't think G6 can be defended
like this Knight is actually really
clutch
because it's preventing Queen D6 and 95
.
the question is am I mating
hmm
not meaning
foreign
probably not so much better here
okay now it's looking better
I just want to Shish Kebab
did I just miss Rook G5 no
I was a Canada move though
G6
so Bishop E2 I just gotta bring in more
attackers
and blocks a bit tied down
so the E5 Bishop C4
or E5 I just take
foreign
D5 Rook G1
I think it's mating now
that wasn't easy
okay at 3.9 seconds
when it goes to show you can live in the
on the one second increments
you probably should uh managed my time a
bit better in the future
that was a cool game though I
um I really botched the opening
night of six
yeah maybe uh Bishop E3 maybe it's just
this line Queen d8
ah 95.
yeah I was trying to rely more on memory
than actual understanding of the
position it's just really backfiring
okay let me
let me refocus playing vugar the strong
player
C3 Sicilian
C4 is a line continue playing this
against me at some point
Pages B6
yeah they're weird tactics uh there's
still maybe weird tactics
I already go wrong
I think queen queen C7
I think I already went wrong unless I
have an id4
tx6 takes
maybe it's playable
that's not what I want though
but maybe what I need
I have a bad feeling about this if I get
one more move in like E5
yeah so E5 how bad is this
I mean White's gonna have the bishop
hair
at least I have a good Bishop
I'll Bishop B1
uh nice move
foreign
[Music]
rookie Yates
it looks like I'm losing a pawn
if the queen moves to D file then I can
safely take
the A6 takes ticks
uh it doesn't quite work
Queen D7
I want to play this and threaten me and
get off the file
I don't think white can win a pawn right
away because take six I hit the queen
oh never mind
I stand corrected
yeah I wanted to like take take the Deep
eight
and there's Rook D2
we Rook D2 94.
I also have Queen C6 here
foreign
way too slowly I'm down over two minutes
on the clock
foreign
scheme
I'm hoping for this tactic like rookie1
and queen G2 mate
that's not gonna happen though
I miss my knight
I'll take oh no my queen
to D4 coming
a sack everything it might be stalemate
I resign
oh that's a rough game
I think I got into trouble in the
opening there
this idea
I think Bishop G5 Rook D1
because the move I want to play is Queen
E7 but 94.
I wonder if I had to play something like
Bishop E7
because I can't play Bishop E7 in this
position because takes takes 24.
and just be seven right away and then I
can't play B6
is the question how to develop this
bishop
I remember a line is to take and then
just avoid the C4 variation
okay playing Ural
a low rated opponent
but International master
I've had this position with black a
couple times
so far this tournament
my first time having it is white
um
uh yeah this E6 line
so Bishop D6 Bishop B5
Bishop G7
very peculiar
I wonder if black wants to go for this
idea
to Queen B3 I think is a approach here
so if C4 is just Queen C2 and there's no
Bishop F5
ah didn't Wesley play something like
this against not against nihal
saw some game like very briefly
foreign
maybe Geary no it was like Champions
chest to her like after the
cgc
I could take
just get the bishop hair
and knights remain superfluous
and maybe that wasn't the best idea but
okay it's something rookie one
nicing is the bishop controls B8
so I don't really have to worry about
Rook b8s
there's this idea
try and pin the pawn to the bishop
don't think it does that much though
it's tempting to take the queen
foreign
very typical London structure
Rook B7 is another threat
or B7 Bishop A6
yeah with the bishop error I want to
open the position
box helping me in doing so I mean I am
left with a isolated Pawn but the spawn
is also isolated
and Bishop G3 Bishop D2
Bishop d
3
A4 is going to come
before I just take it
Adam and Rook returns
you're a bit of D3 first
oh there's a funny line
okay oh no my Pawn takes takes takes I
take on D5 and then both things are
pinned like both pawns are paint even
though they both kind of defend the
night
and Black's not gonna walk into this but
it's a possible trap
and yeah the point is the pressure of
the pawn
so Rook
I think I take
Bishop C4
not sure about this line
I think I would dock material though
so after it takes Bishop C4 and
threatening Bishop A6 and also
to take the bishop
Bishop D2 Rook C2
if ever it takes takes that should be
fine
I think it's leading to one big trade
but I'm hoping in the very end that like
somehow I'll be up a pawn
so when C6 or A4
5
I'm not winning A4
but I think I'm winning C6
uh there's Rook C7
there's a funny line where both Rooks
are attacked and I just
like play B5 like B4 B5
expecting Bishop A5 here
I'm not going to take either Rook I
before
because I think I'm winning C6
hello
of B6
I was debating which thing to take with
but
like there are so many different
captures but uh yeah yeah this is now
completely winning
C8
okay that was a cool game
now we have a break
yeah very positional London game
oop
okay new game I didn't lose too much
time
here we go oh let me switch this layout
a little bit
okay
okay so let's still prep
wasted a little bit of time there
in D2 still Theory
um
I think 95 first
not giving the option of taking
Bishop E6
foreign
new territory for me
I mean it's a familiar structure
but most people don't play like this
wow
so E4 looks attractive
E4 ticks takes there's D4
I'm gonna take with Bishop though
somebody takes takes with Bishop
and E4 is such a thematic break
especially when locks a little bit on
the back foot
now I'm thinking Bishop H6
this is one of the main Defenders of the
king side for black
foreign
I do have to be a little bit careful
about Queen B6
but there's also the resource of taking
and playing E5
sorry the knights I mean we might see
some exchange stock
it shouldn't be that great like I take
here I can take
now we're going into some end game
there's Queen G5
[Music]
um
let's go for this
the epon looks weak but it's hard to
attack
Simple Plan
yeah B5 is coming
I could play Rook A1 Rook d8
foreign
so b492
I kind of can see the D file
but there's no penetration
maybe Knight D4 soon
or Knight F4
let's see three is interesting
C3 is terrible
let's play this
yeah C3 would allow Rook D3
E6 Knight F6
I wonder if I can just go for a meeting
attack
and that F6 looks pretty strong the king
could maybe sneak into
sliding into
opponent's DMs
C3 is a candidate move
plays G4 first
wow
and this move
ah then there's C3
big
I think that's okay actually
I wind up with funny Pawns
thank you
Eric wants to teleport to G8
5 H5 H6 was an idea
yeah it looks shaky for luck
foreign
so it's really nice if it works
because it doesn't work I'll be kind of
sad
but the the nylon F6 it creates so many
mating ideas
so it takes its force made in three
and I just want to take and then
mate with the same pattern
which do they call it the Arabian mates
or the hook mates
ah it's not quite winning
[Music]
hmm
foreign
foreign
foreign
now
okay
oh man opponent just gifted me that uh
Apon
I probably should have been losing
that was a messy ending I mean yeah
A2 should have been played and then yeah
white should just be losing there
I even hesitated like I was not
expecting
black to even allowed Knight takes A3
or the game yeah during these games I
don't really I mean I just don't look at
chat
so generally titled Tuesday streams it's
more about me trying to focus on playing
good chess
rather than interacting with chat but I
hope people are being entertained
hopefully learning a thing or two
um yeah I'll go back to Sicilian and
haven't been scoring well today in
Sicilian
let's see if I can turn that around
okay I mean it's similar to the Fabiano
game
I wonder maybe I can try and transpose
but maybe not
wait F4
I thought Queen B6 is a move
wait
I might be forgetting but
maybe there's a line Knight A4
I played this when I was like a child I
used to play Knight P3 before F4
so Queen B4 C3
I'm going into this with almost no
knowledge
one of my first chess coaches like
taught me this line is white this was
the main thing I used to play
so Queen
[Music]
and queen Diego Quincy Southerner
Quincy Southern
now you hear maybe Queen B8
can I take
not sure what to do
an idea to take in visual C6
huh
a little bit less space a little bit
less time to
take
would be nice to get in B5 I don't think
B6 is too weak
it still might be six
foreign
here
[Music]
let's see five squares nice
foreign
D6
it looks bad but if I can hold on to the
E Pawn
e for some idea
G4
okay this line looks too funny to pass
up
Tetris piece incoming
[Music]
I want to make the diamond
achieved
I'm using my diamond as a weapon
uh-oh someone's using their Rook as a
weapon
foreign
[Music]
foreign
G6
Queen C2
we can see to E2 Queen D2 King H5
Now Quincy tweaking G6 in that line
oh they're Queen E6
King G5
Passat
I'm just getting made it
one in this queen E6
threading this now
let's go okay
oh I came I was a close one
that was a really close one
I didn't need a duck there
I was a beautiful finish too Bishop
issue
I assume yeah King F1 Bishop G3 is also
winning
real quick let me make the board smaller
just to see the names
and zoom in a little bit
komsky up there where's Fabi
don't tell me I passed Fabi
wait I passed fobby and farouza
I assume they just reach quit then
oh no my
my uh super GMS
I'm playing Chicago
okay good thing I realized
uh I know jagalco's repertoire
um
play D6
so I was not expecting Queen D4
this is just a bad line
I think
oh I was expecting Knight takes
okay let's try and recover
um
there's takes takes
I play 95 actually
this might be playable
and Bishop G7
yeah no time for crying
let's have to make do with what I have
funny line G4 Bishop D7
I doubt that works but after it takes
takes I do attack F3
thanks for subbing
dad's making him think that's a good
sign or a bad sign
it might be just thinking how to destroy
me
wow
okay
so take take
Queen D6 just
looks fine
there's a blind spot I was only looking
at Pawn takes for a while
so not even down upon here
maybe a little bit worse
um castling
or queen side castings coming
A6
I like this bishop
I don't like this Pawn though
basically for maybe an idea okay so I
have
foreign
[Music]
that's shaky
and if I get in D5 maybe it's not too
bad
D5 and then Knight C4
hard to achieve though
some A5 idea
and Knight A5 as well
lose a pawn
it should be okay though
uh
H7 F6
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
I can't believe it
that's so sad
what did I do
I just didn't have time to figure it out
uh okay
oh it's so sad
my Bishop got clumsy
I just had to play like King year here
and it's just a drawn
wow
uh yeah even maybe is King C6 the final
mistake
no King C6 King D7 is still a draw
Bishop AIDS I made so many mistakes this
game
I think I think now it's losing
Ah that's so embarrassing
to lose a position that should have been
uh should have been in Fortress
I had chances earlier too at the two
Bishops
good game though that was a fun game
and so a little bit heartbreaking had my
chances
that was a fun tournament though I hope
people enjoyed it
I was in better form than usual hey it's
Tanya wait did Dania read
oh Dania sent her Reid
thank you Dania
sorry if I missed that
or maybe I didn't miss it
alert box is catching up
if you're just joining
oh I lost this position to Chicago
not only did I lose this position I lost
this position
good job Joe Bava oh
okay finished in 30th